i'm going to talk about how to improve
the deaf experience
i'm already introduced so i will not uh
read again but originally this well the
title is how to
turn out as a 10x without dying in the
intent or a 10x developer
but the agenda is motivation why am i
interest in the generator and then we
are going to see in a general overview
of hygiene
specifically
hygiene it is one of this kind and we
are going to do a demo and at the end
some conclusion with some develop very
happy developer testimonies
okay let's start with motivation
what was my motivation in this topic is
so as many i love to have a free time so
i don't like to work a lot right
but
seriously uh well there was a challenge
or a project a couple of years ago it
was a tool created like four years ago
to handle more than 20 sites
and
and they needed to be more solid so this
started as a prototype to create it in
just two weeks
and four years of adjustments and
decisions and
technical doubt
well this code was not a standard
because there were a lot of violence
between the 20 sites
and we had more than 60
forms to rewrite so
the challenge it was we were only six
developers and two of them were just
finished school and of course very
little time so as you can imagine there
was a huge
challenge and when i say these forums
well i'm talking let's see it this is a
screenshot of all the folders
uh another things that we needed to take
into account is that some of these forms
had some tests 80 percent javascript
versus 20 ts the
file and folder structure was a mess as
you can imagine and they were very
different
and
there were a lot of bugs
there was a very bad practices so we had
secondary effects and
in functions change of values and
generally the lack of experience with
the framework and to answer and to
finish well we were in the middle of the
pandemic every one of us were in our
houses so we were working at home so my
question is what would you do
well
maybe
something like that
to
parallel the work to assign developers
more senior developers with more complex
uh
tasks
but the problem with this scenario is
that we have a high risk to not deliver
on time
or
there's no warranty that we follow good
practices or the best practices to the
code due to the time so we will have a
lot of bugs and
do also
like today's we need to train new people
so we need to programming
and i will explain it more
we also thought in automatizing
basically to have the
developers
or programmers and a lot of this work
was very repetitive so that's why we
wanted to do it in an ultimate way
and
and also with this
less things to train the new people
i love to show you this
comic from
xaqd
because this is a theory how the
automation should work you have the work
the writing code then the work increase
or the task increases
then there's a point where the
automation takes over the original work
and then reduct and then you have the
free time
this is a theory
but the the reality is like this you
have the work the writing code
then we're not perfect so that's why we
need the debugging more job more work
then the the
requirements change there's a rethinking
ongoing development and there's no time
for original task anymore
and of course
this is what usually what happened
because we didn't want to do that and
our seniors developer came back and
helped us
that's why i started to
study
the code generators i'm not talking
about compilators i'm talking about
tools or resources that help to create a
certain and particular source code
and
it's like a
source code
and we have three type
project generators snippets and models
by the way this classification is on my
own i invent it
so if you want to talk about it in the
community or on twitter well maybe you
can help me how to change this okay
let's start with uh we have this one
create
react app with all these projects that
well
these generators
that allowed you to start a project so
the first day we were talking about
young main generators and the
characteristics of them are using just
to start the price the project
but the bath thing are very difficult to
personalize and there's only just one
use
so i think this type of generator was
not you
good enough for our project the second
one is the code snippets
and you can have it in all ide and
recently github co-pilot that can
allowed you to have all these with the
context of the code that you have around
you and the characteristic of this
snippets are used to create a repetitive
code in a file you can create it or
install it
and
[Music]
i uh
bad thing is you need to
it's not so easy to share it with your
colleagues and there's no standard so
you can have a snippet with
tabs or spaces
there's a lot of things
and
last is the angular schematics is the
last one of these generators
these ones
have this all these files and everything
with all the features complete features
so
if you come from the hp
[Music]
a php well you have this controller
and these model generators
are the one that are more adapted to
this project because
you can standardize them it's very easy
to share with the rest of the team
you don't have to
memorize
the only downside is they are only
available for specific frameworks
and if the
is like the javascript ecosystem without
angular is well it's like this
photograph
so
there is
here is where hygiene
enter this is a creator or generator of
these models and can be used in any type
of project
so and also with another languages
and you don't need to learn a language
you don't need to to learn this science
syntax systems
so you can learn more a little bit about
this
the variable name and you close it and
that's it
so it's very simple to use at the
beginning
and it's very
personal you can
create the generator and it's very easy
to share you can upload it to the repo
and that's it so how does this work
there are three main concepts the first
one is the prompt
it's a different questions that you post
to the user so we can
know and
so the generation can run for example i
want a new model in my project what is
the name for this new model okay let's
say one
then then
we have the template
these are
files that are used as the base
and so we have our variable
one
we have our template gs css and java
and all these
templates will take this variable and
create new files
and
here are using the variable with this
name but it's not like that there are
other variables
in javascript you can have
export one or
class one
and lasted we have injectors that are
similar file for these templates but to
inject this code so we already have
these
files created by the
template but then we need an app to run
this template
so the injector knows where to put this
variable of one
inside of
dot gs
and
basically to connect our modules
okay
let's see
our demo
first of all this is a project that is
pretty simple
is hello world
and what we need to have with hygiene is
safe i usually put it in depth hygiene
and with that we have this dependency
and we need to create a new folder that
is a template
the call is template
and also to create a generator
new
and because i'm going to create hello
world
this is my structure
now i will create the prompt
and i already have a snipper
this is only
export model
with the type name message
and it's a way to declare
uh
the questions
that we're going to
ask to the user
and the question to whom you are going
to say hello
and then we have our form
or
we create our template
and
the syntax it is with these three
dashes
here i have the hello file
or the folder that has another file with
edit.js
and i will
place it
in that
folder
and here
i will have the name of the format
dot yes
and
introduce console.log
and again
inside the content again the name
name is in an upper
case
with if i have it like this
the first character will be also in an
upper case this is very useful and
before running this we need to go to our
package
json we need to add
this new hello
and ready
we are ready to run it
and here we have
our question
and the answer
i can create another one
and for example the j is lowercase but
in that part is upper
okay
so
what is interesting here is i can do it
as many times as i need it
hello peter for example
this is the hello world but let's see
another case more complicated case this
is a server dot gs
in all express and
is in this webpage
as index.js
and api so let's see a couple of example
i will run
the server
this is the home page
it's very ugly
with the users
but let me change the screens
and here we have
this server
if i'm new in the project and i'm
telling well you have to create a new
page
so the programmer that is in this
project well let's run just one
one instruction
like this
and the name of the page is about
i'm telling no because it's a static and
as you can see
there are three files
css gs and html and there is
the something there inject
if i'm going to that
index.html i can see
this line so i can reach to this new
page
otherwise well
in in the about page we have this html
css gs and all of them are linked
also i have an example for the back end
people
i run the same
the product
and it's the same
it create a new endpoint inside of the
folder i don't need to think
in what folder
i must go
for example
you need to replace this with actual apa
behavior well
i will have an error
but as a programmer the message is
weight is like my tmb will tell me
instructions and also it creates a text
that is linked for this function
so it's like telling me you need to
create a test for you apa because these
are the
best practices that we have as a team
also in the controller there is this
line
this must be in singular not pro not
plural
i will copy
this information
let me erase the
arrow
let's go to the page
and here we have the information
this is the demo let me let me go back
to my slides
okay
how this project ended if you remember
our problem well we were
with a high risk and not to deliver on
time so we
do it without working extra time so we
achieve it there were no warranty that
the code will follow the good practices
if you remember
well these best practices were from the
generator
everyone
wrote in very similar code thanks to
this template we also use functions
created with a secondary effect
it was not so easy and also people run
tests so
that was uh the first
it was their own decision to run all
these tests
also well
there was some bugs due to the time
but because we rely on the generated
code we only review the rest of the
rewritten code because
we knew which part was auto generated
we needed to train new people well as a
matter of fact
new developers were creating features
in very little time
and
you don't need to know
the entire project context
and well there are some testimonies of
some people that use this tool in this
project
and well
say that
the generator did almost all the work i
still need to add proper test cases
or
using it can focus more in the business
rules and not in the project
configurations
and
this
with generation many of the bugs were
simple updates
updating markup on the video
players were ready to be implemented
last
but not least the links if you want to
know more a little bit about this
these are the resources you will have it
in the community chat and also you can
check all my slides and here i have all
the snippers if you want to create the
prompts the templates the injectors
and i have the hygiene link
egs the templating language
inquirer which is the prompt
the repo of hygiene that i just showed
you
and
you want another option with javascript
with a
we have plop dot gs
but uh us
because we are using more javascript and
you can have more bugs you need to
program more things
and you have all the options here
and that's it thank you very much